negotiators at un's cop 27 climate
Summit in Egypt have approved an
historic deal on compensation for
vulnerable Nations after days of
gridlock countries at the summit agreed
to set up a loss and damage fund to help
the nation's most at risk of climate
change disasters calls for such a fund
have dominated the last two weeks of
talks the details of the deal still have
to be negotiated including which
countries would foot the bill now while
the deal has won praise many officials
say it falls short on both loss and
damaged provisions and on commitment to
reducing emissions here's what eu's
climate policy Chief Franz timmermans
had to say we are proud of our
contribution to the creation of this
fund that will serve the interest of
those most in need of support but I urge
you to acknowledge when you walk out of
this room that we have all fallen short
in actions to avoid and minimize loss
and damage we should have done much more
our citizens expect us to lead that
means
far more rapidly reduce emissions
DW climate reporter Ajit naranjan joins
me now Ajit so they've agreed on a deal
where richer countries will pay poorer
countries will help them out to uh to
deal with the damage climate change has
done what does this mean in Practical
terms
it means that rich countries are now
forced to not only look at helping poor
countries adapt so building higher sea
walls and things like that or clean up
their energy grids and kind of helping
them build renewable energy and wind
turbines and solar panels and so on but
also that they're accepting some of the
financial responsibility for extreme
weather events that have been made worse
by the fossil fuels we've burnt
disproportionately in countries like
Germany and the US in France and so on
and so this is a huge step forward
because for 30 years or so poorer
countries have kind of been asking for
this and all these climate talks it's
never been something that's even been on
the agenda this year for the first time
it got put onto the discussion table and
after kind of huge two weeks of
incredibly intense negotiations
countries like economies like the EU and
the US which have previously blocked all
attempts at this have relented to some
degree and said they'll set up a fund
so it's a big step forward but there are
those who say that this fund already
falls short of what is needed
exactly I mean there's two ways you can
look at it the first is that rich
countries definitely do not want to
accept any liability for the damages
done because they feel that if they I
mean one of the big barriers to them
setting up the fund in the first place
with this feeling that if they agree to
any type of financial responsibility
then they'll be left with a bill that'll
run into the trillions of dollars
the second aspect of this is that
they've repeatedly failed to keep their
promises so in the climate Summit in
2009 in Copenhagen rich countries agreed
to pay poor countries a hundred billion
dollars a year by 2020. that money never
materialized it got to about 83 billion
by 2020 and even now today they're still
trying to catch up and get to that 100
billion numbers so I think there's a lot
of skepticism from the poorest countries
that the amount of money needed will be
even put in the spot
okay so apart from the fund what else is
in the deal that's been agreed in
Channel check and more importantly
what's not in the deal so there's a lot
of technicalities in which there's been
progress uh on all sorts of areas but
the key thing that's missing really from
here is very clear statements about
getting rid of fossil fuels so the only
line that the deal contains referring to
them is saying getting rid of unabated
unabated coal power which means coal
power plants that haven't been fitted
with technology to capture the carbon
dioxide from them and phasing out
inefficient fossil fuel subsidies
there's no clear definition on what
unabated actually means in this context
how good these carbon capture
Technologies need to be and there's no
clear definition on what inefficient
means when you're subsidizing fossil
fuel projects what's really absent from
this document that we saw this morning
is words like oil and gas which are
fossil fuels that when you burn them
heat the planet and we know from the
science the science reports that this
same declaration welcomed explicitly
they make it very clear we need to
rapidly get rid of these fossil fuel
sources there's still room in the mix
for a small amount by 2050. but then
with the Technologies to capture them in
place and definitely on a scale that's
drastically lower than what we've got
now right so a mixed result then in
terms of climate policy in Egypt thank
you very much uh DW climate reporter